Speaker 1: When you spend months predicting
a massive, overwhelming red wave where you
say Republicans are going to win everything
and they're going to win everything easily,
and then it doesn't happen. You have to start
figuring out who do you blame? And the Republican
Party is floating the idea of blaming Donald
Trump. Increasingly, over the last 12 or so hours,
12 to 16 hours since we started getting results
in in the midterms. Republicans have been slamming
Trump for the election disaster, which will at
best be a red ripple. The red wave is gone. The
question now becomes, does this in any way impact
Donald Trump's plans to announce for 2024? There
has been a dramatic shift in the betting markets
in terms of who voters, rather, who bettors
believe will be the eventual Republican nominee.
Let's take it step by step. And we actually go to
Fox News articles for this Fox News article
published early this morning. Conservatives point
finger at Trump after Republicans underwhelming
election results. He's never been weaker.
Many conservatives say Tuesday's election
shows it's time to move on from Trump.
All. This is a quote from Michael Brendan
Doherty, a senior writer at the National Review.
All the chatter on my conservative and Republican
channels is rage at Trump. Like I've never seen
the one guy he attacked before Election Day. Was
DeSantis the clear winner? Meanwhile, all his guys
are asking the bed. Real Clear Politics reporter
Phil Wegman says Republican source tells me after
tonight, with Trump candidates underperforming
and DeSantis winning by double digits, 2024 is
a free for all. Everybody in the water, if you
want to take on Trump, he's never been weaker.
Mm. Anecdotal tweets one user Max Nordahl. Kari
Lake over. Karen Robson. Doug Mastriano over Lou
Barletta. Mehmet Oz over. Dave McCormick. J.R.
Mmajunkie. Trump's big November 15 announcement
should be an endorsement of Ron DeSantis for
2024. We can do better. The Reagan Battalion.
Time to move on from Trump. If DeSantis in Florida
wildly overperformed all the hand-picked and Trump
supported Republicans in other swing districts,
particularly if they lose, well, then, gosh,
that is going to be a fascinating new narrative
that will be commented upon by positively no
one. Another Fox News article Trump blasted
across media spectrum over Republicans Midterms
Performance Bigger Loser Tonight. Remember
we spoke last week with Angelo Carusone and
Angelo Carusone agreed with my perspective on Fox.
Trump and Republicans 2024. They're not abandoning
Trump yet. But they are setting up an escape
hatch, an eject button. Call it what you will,
wherein they are starting to seed interviews with
voters saying, I kind of like DeSantis over Trump.
They are starting to publish articles about others
are saying Trump's time may have come and gone.
Let's look at a little bit of of this article.
As the midterm results rolled in and the red wave
longed hope for had not materialized, many pundits
and journalists pointed their fingers at Trump.
Former Obama campaign strategist
David Plouffe on MSNBC said,
I think you have to say Donald Trump has
now presided over two disastrous midterms.
Given the history of presidents in power,
Democrats controlling all of Washington inflation,
this should have been a much stronger night for
Republicans. A bunch of reasons for that. But
at the top of them is Donald Trump. He's deeply
unpopular. He supported a bunch of horrible Senate
candidates who may end up coughing up the football
here. MSNBC's Chris Hayes said Republicans ascribe
to Trump a totemic power he does not have. He
screwed his own power. He is unpopular. He screwed
you today. Screwed you. It's not the full story,
but it is part of the story. And the sooner you
dump him, the better it is for the Republican
Party and American democracy. ABC's Jonathan
Karl said it was unclear who would control
Congress, but Trump is the goat. What? I am
not the greatest of all time quote What I can tell
you is the biggest loser tonight is Donald Trump.
One on CNN, conservative commentator Scott
Jennings offered another blunt analysis.
Saying, quote, There's a potential narrative
out of this night that if you're a discerning
Republican voter trying to figure out the future
direction of the party, we once again learn Trump
is not a national winner for the Republicans. But
DeSantis may be the next evolution of someone who
can marry what you like about Trump, but recover
some people that went away from the party during
Trump. We'll link to these articles and you can
read all the quotes. Okay. We don't yet have all
the results, but it's not looking particularly
good. I'm going to show you a stunning number.
For months and months and months, Trump has
either been leading the betting markets for
2024 Republican nominee or tied with Ron DeSantis.
Months and months and months and months. This is
not a poll, okay. This is people bet. Who do
you believe will be the Republican nominee?
Over the last few hours. Ron DeSantis has built
the biggest lead in the betting markets that he
has had this election cycle. When you ask people
to bet on the question who will win the 2024
Republican presidential nomination? The leader is
now Ron DeSantis. The way this works is these are
betting contracts. So with the Santos, you have to
put up $0.41 to win a dollar. If it's the Santos,
whereas with Trump, you only have to put
up $0.33 to win a dollar. The idea being.
The more you have to put up to win a dollar,
the more likely an outcome it is. This is we
have not seen these numbers at any point. It is
the weakest that Trump has been in years. And the
next question is, does this change Trump's
plan to announce his candidacy on Tuesday?